in Würzburg in Unterfranken steht mitten
auf dem Campus der Julius Maximilians
Universität di Mena architektonisch ein
Highlight doch mit dem schicken Bau
gibt's ein echtes Problem das Gebäude
ist frisch saniert trotzdem ist die
Mensa geschlossen seit sage und schreibe
fünfeinhalb Jahren es gibt immer wieder
neuen Ärger der freistat bekommt seine
Baustelle einfach nicht in den Griff bei
den Studierenden ist der Frust groß ich
war in den ganzen 5 Jahren die ich jetzt
studiert habe noch nicht einmal in der
Mensa weil die eben dicht ist weil die
zu ist und ich find es für uns
Studierende unerträglich ich bin jetzt
im ersten Semester habe aber schon von
meiner Schwester die schon vor ein paar
Jahren hier studiert hat schon damals
mitbekommen dass die Mena eben
geschlossen war und das finde ich ein
bisschen fragwürdig Anfang 2018 wird die
MA geschlossen der Grund das Gebäude
muss komplett saniert werden laut Plan
des Staatlichen Bauamtes Würzburg sollen
die Arbeiten spätestens im Frühjahr 2021
abgeschlossen sein doch daraus wird
nichts ein Wasserschaden zerstört
bereits fertiggestellte Bauteile die
Folge die menser wird zur Dauerbaustelle
der Eröffnungstermin muss immer wieder
verschoben werden erst aufs Frühjahr
2022 dann auf den Spätsommer
2023 doch beim Probebetrieb treten
plötzlich Störungen an den
raumlufttechnischen Anlagen auf mit
anderen Worten die LFT funktioniert
nicht richtig der Laden bleibt dicht
oben drein steigen die Kosten auf stolze
61 Millionen Euro die Frustration unter
den Studierenden ist natürlich groß und
die ersatzmenser diese ist eben ab 12
Uhr überfüllt und natürlich fragen wir
uns alle wann kommen wir überhaupt
wieder in die menser rein in die große
das staatliche Bauamt Würzburg versucht
erst gar nicht das sanierungsdesaster
schön zu reden schriftlich heißt es uns
ist die unbefriedigende Situation für
Studierende und Mitarbeiter der
Universität sehr ser bewusst wir
arbeiten deshalb mit Hochdruck an der
Inbetriebnahme der Mensa und bitten um
Verständnis für die weitere
Verzögerung viele sind nur noch genervt
dass sie kreuz und quer über den Campus
laufen müssen um eine Mahlzeit zu
ergattern hier gibt's ja auch nicht so
viel Alternativen wo man essen gehen
könnte deswegen finde ich schon dass es
langsam mal fertig werden müsste die Uni
Würzburg ist ja schon eine große Uni und
ich verstehe nicht was da falsch
gelaufen ist bei der Planung nach
neuester Planung sollen hier wieder
Anfang 2024 Studentinnen und Studenten
Platz nehmen können um zu essen wenn ja
wenn nicht wieder irgendein Problem
dazwischenkt